it's safe to say that rogue one a Star
Wars story was one of if not my most
anticipated film of the year I have
lived and breathed Star Wars my entire
life ever since my dad sat me down with
the original VHS tapes and made me watch
the original trilogy I have loved this
thing since I was a little boy I've
played with the toys I've seen you guys
know this I love Star Wars so naturally
going to this film I was on edge I was
trembling my heart was beating I was
waiting to see just every little moment
of this movie I wanted to see how the
very first ever Star Wars anthology film
would open would they have a crawl would
they not have a crawl what would they do
differently with the score what would
the characters be like how would
everything wrap up I've avoided all
theories and speculation articles about
this film I have not read a single
spoiler which by the way this review
will also be spoiler free I will do a
spoiler review for you guys later this
weekend but I'm trying to get the point
across that I went into this film as a
humongous fan but also with an open mind
who obviously knows what the majority of
this film is going to be about because
if you've seen episode 4 a new hope you
know that Leia had Death Star plans but
how did these plans come into the hands
of the rebels and that's where this
movie comes into play the character jyn
erso portrayed by Felicity Jones and a
team of rebels go out on a very small
mission to attempt to retrieve these
Death Star plans and hopefully turn the
tide in the battle against the Empire
let's start with the pros first I really
like the fact that this was a grounded
realistic Star Wars movie it was sort of
like a very fun action film that takes
place in the Star Wars universe
it feels suitably small-scale despite
its massive budget and incredible
special effects despite the fact that
they're travelling all over the galaxy
to many planets there was something that
felt more contained about this movie
which was refreshing the film also
features gorgeous action set pieces with
mind-blowing ly good CGI and I'm talking
about the space stuff the ship-to-ship
battles
the stuff on the beach battle that we're
all very excited to see the CG here is
virtually flawless it is so well
imprinted within this film that it feels
completely seamless with the human
characters and there's a lot of
sequences especially within the beach
battle where you see the 80 80s walking
around and it's often shown from the
perspective of the humans on the ground
and so you get a way of relating to it
and it also depicts the size very well
which is something that Gareth Edwards
who directed this film did a really good
job in with Godzilla making him look
gigantic you really felt the size of
that creature in that movie and you feel
that with a lot of the CG in this film
it's very well incorporated with the
people that are on the ground the
performances are all almost uniformly
great Felicity Jones is terrific diego
luna's very good Riz Ahmed is great in
regards to the new characters that are
in this film I would say that Donnie Yen
and k2s oh the droid are my favorite new
additions to the Star Wars universe
I thought Donnie Yen was a complete
badass in this movie all of his fight
scenes were really cool and I liked his
character there's a lot of good humor
there and speaking of humor k2s o is by
far the shining example of it in this
film he has so many great lines he's
such a fun and likable character he's
easily my favorite part of this movie in
regards to the characters I also
appreciated the brief callbacks and
references to other Star Wars films
they're there but they're not
overpowering the film is wise enough to
trust its own story and be fun in its
own right while not relying too much on
things of the past that we appreciate
but they're there in small doses and if
you pick up on some of them it's going
to make the experience more entertaining
for you the aesthetics of the film are
also beautiful the production design
feels used dirty lived in the type of
Star Wars we like to see that sort of
dirty futuristic world where it feels
tangible and real and I love the prop
creatures as well that were on display a
lot of really fun stuff there also this
film puts to rest a decade's long
complaint with Star Wars fans I can't
say what it is until I talk about it in
this
our video but this film addresses a very
specific complaint that many people have
had with the Star Wars universe and it
did it in a very emotionally satisfying
way and let's talk about a certain
character named Darth Vader that we all
know was in this movie he has an
incredibly awesome scene an extremely
satisfying scene that gave me goosebumps
it is great it is great which leads me
into my negatives because this film is
not perfect
rogue one I think is an enjoyable film I
do not think it's a great film to be
honest I left the theater a little
underwhelmed I was kind of disappointed
mainly with the characterization jyn
erso is really the only character that
were given a reason to root for or care
about the majority of the other
characters are set up in a very sloppy
fashion for the first act of this film
there are aspects of the first act that
did feel messy this film underwent
extensive reshoots this was very well
publicized a lot of people were
concerned about that and it does show
there's an intriguing friendship set up
between Donnie yen's character and when
Jiang's character but there's never a
reason given for why they're friends we
actually learn nothing zero about either
of those characters they're just funny
and the script has some good lines for
them and they felt unfortunately safe
there just wasn't anything there beyond
the let's make some funny jokes and I
liked Donnie Yen because he's the badass
side character he can be that cool
character who comes in and kicks ass and
you're like yeah you're cool and k2s oh
can be that cool droid character who
comes in and tells jokes and you're like
yeah you're funny but there isn't much
else to them the characters that really
needed focus like Diego Luna except for
one real outburst that he has we learn
nothing about him either instead of more
characterization being given to these
characters and more reasons for us to
care about them we get strange out of
play scenes like a mind-reading tentacle
monster I don't really know why that was
in the movie Forest Whitaker is an actor
that I really like his
in the film is based off of a character
who appears in the Clone Wars animated
show his voice in this film I can tell
you is probably going to polarize a lot
of people my best way to describe it
would be if someone stepped on my throat
right now and I just started talking
like this whole time yeah like it's I'm
not exaggerating that's really what he
talks like and after a while it's just
kind of like yeah I don't know about
that either there's a character in this
film that is full CGI it's a motion
capture face it is something that had to
be in this film I expected it I figured
it would be involved in some way I just
didn't think it would get as much screen
time as it did and it was very
distracting which leads me to Darth
Vader
now Darth Vader is one of my favorite
characters of all time in fact I think
if you went out in public and polled say
a thousand people who the greatest movie
villain of all time was I bet you Darth
Vader would be at least number two and
probably number one he's amazing Darth
Vader's like the greatest person ever
I love Darth Vader's what I'm trying to
say so the fact that Darth Vader's in
this movie I went to the theater like oh
my gosh I'm about to hear James Earl
Jones talking as Darth Vader and he's in
the movie for about 4 minutes maybe
look I enjoyed the newest Godzilla film
which was also directed by Gareth
Edwards but I think the majority of
people wanted more of Godzilla when they
left that film because Gareth Edwards
for whatever reason was like hey I'm
making a movie with Godzilla it's just
not showing and for whatever reason
again we have a film that has Darth
Vader like he literally has the
opportunity to show Darth Vader for this
entire film and he chooses to show him
like a couple times
why and I know what you're thinking well
you're just being a fanboy for Star Wars
and you want everything to be old like
the way it was you don't want anything
new I loved the force awakens and I went
into the force awakens expecting Luke
Skywalker to be in the film and if
you've seen force awakens you know
it's not really the case he is in there
but not really and I loved it
why because I loved the characters rey
finn poe han solo great characters kept
me invested kylo ren I loved kylo Ren
these characters kept me invested in
this story there isn't a character in
row 1 that I like more than Darth Vader
especially kren ik betrayed by Ben
Mendelsohn who is suitably over-the-top
and I enjoyed his work in this film but
as a character and as a villain he just
does not stand up to Darth Vader so I
can't still him like where's Vader let's
get some more of that because the other
characters in the film aren't as cool or
interesting there's nothing really to
them to make me more invested in them
like I was invested in the characters
and force awakens because when I left
force awakens I was like I actually
don't mind that Luke wasn't in that
movie because their other characters are
great I don't have that feeling with
rogue one which is why I wanted more of
Darth Vader which brings me to that CG
character which I'll talk about in a
spoiler video the majority of his scenes
I was like you could just have a Derby
in those scenes like I don't need this
motion capture guy just have Vader do
this stuff I understand that you need
this specific character to be in the
film because he's integral to this whole
story have him be in like one scene I
figured he'd be like in one scene but he
was in like five or six and for whatever
reason Vader was in literally two and
I'm like I need more please to be
completely honest if you told me that
the reshoots that were done for rogue
one were to add the character of Darth
Vader to this film I'd say that makes
perfect sense that's how little he's
actually in the movie full disclosure my
biggest issue with rogue one is that
nothing surprised me now I did not read
a single Internet article about
speculation theories or spoilers I stay
away from all of that because I'm not
really a fan of that because it's like
oh this could happen this could happen
okay maybe kylo ren's Luke Skywalker
what if that was true Wow that'd be
weird
huh seriously but still having read none
of that information nothing in rogue one
took me off-guard
nothing surprised me
there wasn't a single moment where I was
like wow I didn't expect that safe for
that one thing that I told you addressed
a flaw
with the Star Wars universe that people
have complained about for years that was
the one thing where I was like that's
awesome I love that other than that
everything basically played out the way
I expected it to except for the fact
that I thought there'd be a lot more
Vader I know you're thinking you're
thinking man he really hates rogue one
actually no I enjoyed watching this
movie I think it's good it's just that
when you are a giant Star Wars fan when
Star Wars is special to you when it
means something to you when it has
impacted your life in an emotional way
positively the things that aren't great
about the Star Wars films are going to
stick out to you and they're going to
hit you on a deeper level than I think
most and so that's one of the reasons
why you get such rage over the prequels
and the fact that people flicked out the
force awakens was similar to a new hope
because we expect so much out of these
movies and that's not wrong but at the
same time I must reiterate that I did
enjoy row 1 and I want to see it again I
thought it was a terrifically exciting
and fun action movie but as a Star Wars
film I expected more out of one very
specific thing the thing that makes me
want to watch Star Wars over and over
and over and the thing that's going to
make me show Star Wars to anyone I've
ever met or future children if I do have
them the characters the characters of
Star Wars are what keep us all watching
it and the characters in rogue one let
me down there wasn't a sense of urgency
or intensity with them they were just
funny and likeable and jyn erso
did have a background and there were
reasons to care but I wanted more from
characters because as a huge Star Wars
fan that's what keeps me coming back and
not the space battles not ETA T's not
Darth
Vader's lightsaber it's the characters
it's the fact that I would like to go to
the cantina and have a drink with han
Solo
that's what makes me want to watch Star
Wars the action sequences are amazing in
row one and it is definitely worth
seeing and I will buy the blu-ray it is
a very fun exciting Star Wars movie but
the characters for me we're lacking I'm
going to give rogue one a Star Wars
story of B as I said guys I will do an
in-depth spoiler review very soon
discussing a lot more which will be up
this weekend if you've never seen my
other Star Wars reviews I have reviewed
every Star Wars movie including the
Clone Wars animated film and the holiday
special which of course we all know is
the best movie ever made
no there's going to be a link for that
playlist in just a second here if you
want to check out those other videos
also stay tuned to my wife's channel in
a few days I'm gonna have my initial
reaction to the film I film myself
driving to the theater and leaving the
theater that's gonna be up on her
channel soon and if you missed my
showdown debut the movie trivia show I
had a lot of fun going head-to-head with
Jeff Snyder answering some cool movie
trivia questions there's a link for that
below please do check that out and send
them some love you guys are the best I
hope you enjoy Star Wars rogue one as I
did I must reiterate I enjoyed the film
but it's not a perfect movie and I
wasn't going to sit here and act like it
was just because I love Star Wars thanks
very much for watching guys and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuff my nice
[Applause]
[Music]
you